Is there anything more American than America?
'Cause you can't import original.
You can't fake true cool.
You can't duplicate legacy.
Because what Detroit created was a first...
...and became an inspiration to the rest of the world.
Yeah, Detroit made cars and cars made America.
Making the best, making the finest takes conviction.
And you can't import the heart and soul of every man and woman working on the lab.
You could search the world over for the finer things,...
...but you won't find a match for the American road and the creatures that live on it.
Because we believe in the zoom and the roar and the thrust.
And when it's made here,...
...it's made with the one thing you can't import from anywhere else: American pride.
So let Germany brew your beer.
Let Switzerland make your watch.
Let Asia assemble your phone.
We will build your car.